[Aplausos]
[Música]
el pasado 6 de diciembre del 2020 se
celebraron elecciones legislativas en
venezuela bueno más que elecciones lo
que se celebró fue un enorme pantomima
una parodia a un engaño en definitiva
una gran estafa en la que por supuesto
el partido oficial el presupuesto de
nicolás maduro cosechó la mayoría
absoluta en la asamblea nacional esto es
en el parlamento de venezuela una
mayoría que tiene menos valor que un
boleto de lotería ha rellenado otras en
sorteo cuando los números agraciados
pues ya son conocidos y no no estoy
exagerando porque amigos esto no es una
cuestión de izquierdas ni de derechas de
hecho ni siquiera la internacional
socialista se creía las intenciones del
régimen bolivariano fijaos la
internacional socialista calificó de
legítimas las elecciones convocadas por
el régimen de maduro la internacional
socialista una vez más levanta su voz
para expresar su resuelto apoyo y
solidaridad con el pueblo de venezuela y
con sus fuerzas democráticas que
nuevamente han visto sus libertades y
derechos gravemente vulnerados por el
régimen dictatorial de nicolás maduro en
esta oportunidad con las ilegítimas
elecciones legislativas realizadas en el
día de ayer comunicado de la
internacional socialista del 7 de
diciembre del 2020 si este proceso tuvo
alguna carácter
fue precisamente el de la enorme
abstención que se registró según el
bolivariano consejo nacional electoral
apenas votaron poco más del 30 por
ciento de los venezolanos con derecho a
voto una cifra de participación que el
observatorio contra el fraude un órgano
creado por el propio parlamento redujo
hasta el entorno del 20 por ciento y que
la mesa de la unidad democrática situó
en poco más del 15 por ciento del censo
es decir que el partido de nicolás
maduro se hizo con la mayoría absoluta
del parlamento con el respaldo de apenas
entre el 11 y el 20 por ciento de los
venezolanos y eso eso sin tener en
cuenta todos los amaños chanchullos que
se llevaron a cabo que leéis algunos
ejemplos concretos pues atentos
[Música]
la práctica totalidad de la posición de
la posición real no se presentó y aún
así muchos partidos al menos 8 incluido
el de juan guaidó fueron intervenidos
por la justicia bolivariana a quien puso
al frente de los mismos a quien
consideró oportuno
y si lo habéis escuchado bien entre 2019
y 2020 los tribunales de maduro
depusieron a los líderes de dos partidos
de la oposición para poner al frente de
los mismos a personas digamos más
cómodas para el régimen
y ahí no quedó todo la composición del
órgano electoral fue elegida
irregularmente por el gobierno de maduro
se determinó que en algunas
circunscripciones se votaría
literalmente a mano alzada se alteró la
composición de la asamblea para
favorecer a distritos pequeños
controlados perfectamente por el régimen
del recuento mejor ni hablemos la lista
de irregularidades es larguísima
precisamente por eso ningún país u
organismo internacional medianamente
serio ha reconocido las elecciones como
tal pero un momento porque
sorprendentemente aún nos encontramos
casos como el del ex presidente español
josé luis rodríguez zapatero que no sólo
asistió como observador electoral y
consideró legítimas las elecciones sino
que incluso lamentó que la oposición no
hubiese querido participar en esta
especie de partida de cartas marcadas
ojalá todos estuvieran hubieran decidido
participar yo no sé el psuv a los que no
han decidido no participar porque como
demócrata me siento siempre en la
obligación creo que es un deber de tener
una visión amplia generosa e inclusiva
digo ustedes han decido no participar en
estas elecciones yo no creo que cuando
esto ha decidido alguna parte de la
oposición en venezuela no ha ido bien a
nadie
a nadie tenía la propia oposición ni al
país
y por tanto reflexione
en cualquier caso más allá de la opinión
que podamos tener sobre los motivos que
llevan al zapatero a defender o
blanquear al régimen de nicolás maduró
hoy en visual político queremos
responder a una pregunta clara y concisa
cómo funciona realmente la democracia
bolivariana es decir podemos realmente
referirnos a venezuela como una
democracia de qué forma el gobierno de
nicolás maduro logra mantenerse en el
poder queridos amigos lo que vais a ver
a continuación es una historia de
explotación abuso saqueo y destrucción
estáis preparados pues arranquemos
[Música]
la democracia ficticia amigos los que
seguís habitualmente visual político
sabéis que hemos hablado un montón de
veces sobre venezuela y lo cierto es que
aunque ya a veces parezca que este país
ha desaparecido de los grandes titulares
de actualidad aquí las cosas están tan
mal como siempre lo que desde hace al
menos 20 años en términos venezolanos
quiere decir peor que nunca pero bien
como ya os hemos dicho en este vídeo
vamos a tratar de echar un vistazo a
cómo funciona realmente el estado de
derecho y la democracia bolivariana o lo
que es lo mismo como el chavismo ha
convertido la democracia en una mera
palabra decorativa y lo no es una
acusación o una denuncia gratuita
[Música]
todo solo tenemos que repasar los
informes entre otros organismos de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos de human rigth watch de la
organización de estados américanos o de
la propia oficina del alto comisionado
de las naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos un órgano este último dirigido
por cierto por la mismísima michelle
bachelet ex presidenta de chile y una
persona que en su vida política pues
digamos que tampoco es que fuera
precisamente hostil hostil a la
revolución chavista al menos no creo que
nadie la pueda acusar de ser un peón de
la derecha internacional ni una
marioneta del eje miami madrid
washington al que tantas veces se
refiere el dictador nicolás maduro y si
he dicho dictador porque los resultados
de todos estos informes de derechos
humanos dejan claro que la única persona
que realmente se sigue creyendo eso de
que venezuela es una democracia más o
menos funcional pero una democracia al
fin y al cabo es desgraciadamente el ex
presidente del gobierno de españa josé
luís rodríguez zapatero pero vayamos al
grano profundicemos en la realidad
política y social de este país que dicen
exactamente estos informes sobre
derechos humanos porque empecemos por el
de la onu
[Música]
el informe del alto comisionado de las
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos se publicó en 2019 para su
realización se tuvieron en cuenta todos
los datos recogidos en varias visitas de
funcionarios de la onu entre septiembre
de 2018 y marzo de 2019 gris si bien es
cierto que el régimen de maduro facilitó
al menos de cara a la galería' el
trabajo de estos observadores a varios
centros de detención e incluso permitió
a los evaluadores de la onu hablar con
varios detenidos lo cierto es que ni
siquiera eso su hábito las conclusiones
de estos expertos sobre lo que hoy está
sucediendo en venezuela
y es que amigos las palabras fueron
duras muy duras
chelet denuncia torturas y ejecuciones
en el gobierno de maduro denuncias que
por supuesto persisten todavía a día de
hoy más de un año después de publicarse
el informe porque así es como funciona
el régimen bolivariano es la realidad
que ya nadie quiere ni puede ocultar 25
de septiembre de 2020 bachelet denuncia
más de 2 mil ejecuciones extrajudiciales
en venezuela en 2020 y esto amigos no es
una denuncia aislada de venezuela
ejecuciones extrajudiciales en zonas de
bajos recursos un patrón de graves
abusos policiales que quedan impunes
este último informe por cierto acaba de
salir del horno se trata de la
actualización y ampliación de un informe
de 2018
y qué queréis que os diga las cifras que
ahora la organización de estados
américanos ha puesto sobre la mesa son
simple y llanamente aterradoras según la
oea nicolás maduró es responsable de más
de 18.000 ejecuciones extrajudiciales
más de 15 mil 500 casos de detención y
privación de libertad arbitraria 724
casos de desaparición forzada tan sólo
entre 2018 y 2019 y cientos y cientos de
casos documentados de torturas
incluyendo ojo la violencia sexual y
todo esto sin contar el clima de enorme
violencia y miseria que el régimen ha
creado en las calles nuestro informe da
vida el extraordinario sufrimiento del
pueblo de venezuela e infligido por
nicolás maduró y su régimen la única
conclusión razonable a la que se llega
al examinar la escala y amplitud de los
abusos contra los derechos humanos como
las ejecuciones extrajudiciales las
detenciones arbitrarias y la imposición
de condiciones de vida diseñadas para
causar un gran sufrimiento a la muerte
es que estas acciones constituyen
crímenes de lesa humanidad
jared quien será asesor especial de la
oea amigos represión censura informativa
a censura política persecución a la
disidencia crisis económica a grupos
paramilitares campando a sus anchas
crisis sanitaria a torturas falta de
alimentos y medicinas etcétera etcétera
los informes de todos y cada uno de
estos organismos oficializaban por
decirlo de alguna forma todas y cada
las cosas que ya sabíamos de venezuela
pero que solo nos llegaban a través de
los medios de testimonios de los propios
venezolanos
las naciones unidas han constatado
formalmente en la práctica regular de la
tortura en los centros de detención
mediante electrocuciones asfixia con
bolsa de plástico o privación de agua y
comida palizas y un sinfín de agresiones
más todo esto ha llevado a cabo por
funcionarios del sebin el servicio de
inteligencia venezolano de la guardia
nacional bolivariana y de la dirección
general de contrainteligencia militar
y luego además tenemos el fais las
fuerzas de acciones especiales
venezolanas a las que se les imputa la
creación de auténticos escuadrones de la
muerte escuadrones que se desplazan
hasta su objetivos en furgonetas no
identificadas y en ocasiones incluso sin
matrículas y una vez allí irrumpen sin
ningún tipo de orden judicial en las
casas de supuestos opositores o personas
que digamos les son incómodas al régimen
lo hacen en muchos casos vestidos de
negro y con pasamontañas roban saquean y
detienen a cuantas personas consideran
de hecho este tipo de operaciones son
las que suelen engrosar la lista de
muertes violentas clasificadas por el
gobierno como muertes por resistencia a
la autoridad que suman tal y como hemos
visto más de 18.000 casos tan sólo en
los últimos cinco años y no se trata
sólo de los órganos gubernamentales de
los cuerpos oficiales para nada
el régimen bolivariano ha creado también
unidades militares o mejor dicho para
militares de inteligencia y defensa
utilizando a civiles a través de
estructuras locales como los consejos
comunales las unidades de batalla
bolívar chávez o las redes de
articulación y acción social política
hablamos de estructuras que la práctica
funcionan como unidades paralelas al
estado pero que están directamente a su
servicio o mejor dicho al servicio del
gobierno sus miembros pueden hacer casi
cualquier salvajada para mantener al
régimen sin necesidad de vestir ningún
uniforme y por supuesto como os podéis
imaginar todos estos grupos oficiales
son o actúan con total impunidad entre
otras cosas porque los tribunales de
justicia y los órganos judiciales que
están directamente en controlados por el
gobierno y el psoe el partido socialista
unido de venezuela el partido
todopoderoso el de nicolás maduro y
demás sátrapas bolivarianos así que los
tribunales tienden a no juzgar oa
sobreseer o incluso a tapar los casos de
abusos policiales ejecuciones sumarias o
represión por parte de los diferentes
grupos que conforman la red de acción
bolivariana y luego por si no fuese
suficiente a todo esto tenemos que
añadir la intervención y el control de
los medios de comunicación y la
instrumentalización incluso de los
supuestos programas sociales
el gobierno venezolano cuenta con un
programa de distribución de alimentos
mediante comités locales de
abastecimiento y producción que
distribuyen las llamadas cajas clave que
forman parte de una especie de política
de asistencia social puesta en marcha
por maduro pues bien para acceder a
estas cajas de alimentos hay que
apuntarse y el gobierno debe incluirse
en su lista de distribución el claro
según seas más o menos próximo al
gobierno pues este proceso puede ser más
o menos rápido o incluso reversible y es
que la lista de beneficiarios de los
programas sociales es gestionada
básicamente por estructuras locales del
partido oficialista del partido
socialista unido de venezuela es decir
que si quieres recibir estas ayudas
debes permanecer calladito y tener mucho
ojo con manifestarse en contra del
gobierno y además no olvidéis la difícil
situación económica por la que atraviesa
venezuela pensad que hablamos de un país
en el que las naciones unidas- constató
que muchas personas apenas pueden comer
una vez al día inglés que más de cuatro
millones y medio de venezolanos ya
sufren problemas de desnutrición así que
no acceder a estos programas por muy
míseros que sea puede suponer un gran
problema
chantaje quien dijo chantaje amigos todo
esto no son especulaciones ni siquiera
la denuncia de grupos opositores todas
estas cuestiones han sido contrastadas
por una infinidad de organismos
internacionales el régimen de maduro ha
extendido su control sobre todos los
aspectos de la sociedad venezolana ha
desmantelado las instituciones
democráticas y ha reprimido por la
fuerza cualquier disidencia política
real tal y como hemos visto para lograr
sus objetivos el régimen no ha dudado en
atacar a los periodistas aplacar
violentamente a los manifestantes
encarcelar torturar hacer desaparecer o
asesinar a miles de opositores y luego
para colmo la terrible crisis bueno que
digo crisis el auténtico colapso
económico que vive el país la pobreza no
deja de aumentar la hiperinflación es
incontrolable existe un enorme
desabastecimiento de productos básicos
incluido ojo productos sanitarios y
farmacéuticos para que os hagáis una
idea del desastre en octubre del 2020 se
calculó en más de 5 millones y medio el
número de personas que han abandonado el
país tan solo en los últimos años más de
5 millones y medio de personas para que
os hagáis una idea hablamos ya de uno de
los grupos de población de personas más
grandes de todo el mundo superior al
causado por muchas guerras en términos
reales del pib per cápita se ha hundido
hasta el nivel que tenía ni más ni menos
que él
evidentemente amigos con semejantes
condiciones ya me contaréis qué clase de
democracia va a haber en el país porque
no la democracia no consiste sólo en
votar de hecho es casi lo de menos un
sistema democrático necesita pluralidad
libertad de expresión libertad de prensa
con un estado de derecho eficaz justicia
libertad de manifestación transparencia
una comisión electoral independiente y
en el régimen bolivariano pues no hay
nada de eso porque amigos el régimen de
nicolás maduro es simple y llanamente
una dictadura
[Música]
una cruel dictadura que ha destrozado la
vida de millones de personas y
aniquilado la de miles y miles de
venezolanos porque le resultaba incómodo
es incomprensible que aún haya personas
incluidos como decíamos antes todo un
expresidente del gobierno español que es
algo de intereses espurios sigan
apoyando defendiendo o justificando al
régimen bolivariano no hay otro camino
y este día electoral del 6 de diciembre
de 2020 supone un paso adelante es más
me atrevería a decir que es el principio
del final de los peores momentos que ha
vivido venezuela el principio del final
de un conflicto total el principio del
final de unas sanciones injustas e
incomprensibles
lo que se vivió el domingo 6 de
diciembre de 2020 por mucho que josé
luís rodríguez zapatero se empeña en
decir lo contrario no fueron unas
elecciones democráticas sino una vida
artimaña el enésimo intento del régimen
venezolano de camuflar lo que realmente
son una cruel dictadura pero amigos
llegados hasta aquí turno para ti la
situación en venezuela aparece si
terrible pero lo cierto es encontrar una
solución lo parece aún más por eso te lo
pregunto a ti directamente a ti qué
crees que tendría que ocurrir en
venezuela para que las cosas cambiarán
cómo se podría derribar al régimen de
nicolás maduro sin infringir aún más
daño al pueblo venezolano déjanos tu
respuesta por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ahora vamos debate y si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no dejes de darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a visual polític si es que
aún no lo has hecho una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]